trabajar con un solo capacitor conectado
a una batería no es nada difícil pero
cuando tenemos varios capacitores
conectados a una batería las personas
típicamente se confunden mucho más hay
muchas maneras de conectar varios
capacitores pero si los capacitores
están conectados uno atrás de otro de
esta manera tenemos capacitores
conectados en serie
digamos que estás haciendo un examen y
en el examen te preguntan cuál es la
carga en el capacitor que se encuentra
más a la izquierda lo que algunas
personas tratarán de hacer es esto usar
la fórmula de la capacitancia ya que la
capacitancia es igual a la carga entre
el voltaje pueden poner la capacitancia
del capacitor que está más a la
izquierda que ese 4 para poner el
voltaje de la batería que es de 9 volts
de despejar la carga y obtener que el
capacitor almacena 36 kilos y esta
respuesta está mal para encontrar por
qué está mal y deducir la forma de
encontrar la respuesta correcta en este
tipo de escenario
veamos
qué es lo que está ocurriendo en este
ejemplo cuando la batería se conecta a
una carga negativa comenzará a fluir a
partir del lado derecho del capacitor
que se encuentra del lado derecho el
capacitor 3 y esta carga negativa va a
recorrer todo el circuito hasta llegar
al lado izquierdo del capacitor 1 esto
hace que una carga negativa comience a
fluir del lado derecho del capacitor 1 y
llegue al lado izquierdo del capacitor 2
y esto a su vez hace que una carga
negativa salga del lado derecho del
capacitor 2 y llegue al lado izquierdo
del capacitor 3 las cargas seguirán
haciendo esto y es importante saber algo
aquí debido a la forma en que trabaja
este proceso de carga todos los
capacitores de aquí deberán tener la
misma cantidad de carga almacenada en
ellos tiene que ser de esta manera
viendo el comportamiento de cómo se
cargan estos capacitores pues realmente
no hay otro lugar a donde vaya la carga
tiene que ir al siguiente capacitor lo
cual son buenas noticias
ya que eso significa que para los
capacitores en serie la carga almacenada
en cada capacitor va a ser la misma
así que si encontramos la carga para uno
de los capacitores encontraremos la
carga para todos los demás capacitores
pero como encontramos la cantidad de
carga que es está bueno hay un truco que
podemos usar en estas situaciones
podemos imaginar que reemplazamos estos
tres capacitores con un solo capacitor
equivalente si elegimos el valor
correcto para este capacitor solito
podremos almacenar la misma cantidad de
carga como lo harían estos tres
capacitores en serie la razón de que
esto no sea útil es porque ya sabemos
cómo trabajar con un solo capacitor a
este capacitor imaginario que reemplaza
a todos los capacitores que tenemos
conectados en serie el capacitor
equivalente y le llamamos capacitor
equivalente porque su efecto en el
circuito pues es equivalente a
y de todos los demás capacitores que
están reemplazando y resulta que hay una
fórmula práctica para encontrar la
capacitancia equivalente la fórmula para
encontrar la capacitancia equivalente de
los capacitores conectados en serie luce
así 1 entre la capacitancia equivalente
es igual a 1 entre la primera
capacitancia más 1 entre la segunda
capacitancia más 1 entre la tercera
capacitancia y si hubiera más
capacitores conectados en serie
seguiríamos sumando el inverso de la
capacitancia de cada uno de ellos vamos
a demostrar de dónde viene esta fórmula
en un momento pero por ahora vamos a
acostumbrarnos a usarla para ver qué
encontramos usando los valores de
nuestro ejemplo tenemos que 1 entre la
capacitancia equivalente va a ser igual
a 1 entre 4 paradas más 1 entre 12
fragatas más 1 entre 6 paradas lo que
nos da 0.5 pero tengan cuidado aún
acabamos queremos la capacitancia
equivalente no el inverso de esta
capacitancia así que tenemos que
encontrar el inverso de esta cantidad 1
entre 0.5 para encontrar nuestra
capacitancia equivalente si hacemos esto
nos encontramos que la capacitancia
equivalente para esta serie de
capacitores es de 2 baratas y ahora que
ya hemos reducido nuestro problema de
múltiples capacitores a un problema con
un solo capacitor podemos encontrar la
carga almacenada en este solo capacitor
usamos la fórmula capacitancia es igual
a la carga entre el voltaje y poner los
valores de la capacitancia equivalente y
del voltaje de la batería
podemos hacerlo ya que el voltaje en un
solo capacitor va a ser el mismo que el
voltaje de la batería despejamos la
carga y nos queda que la carga
almacenada en este capacitor equivalente
es de 18 kilos
pero no nos preguntan la carga del
capacitor equivalente nos preguntan la
carga del capacitor que se encuentra
hasta la izquierda pero esto ya es muy
sencillo ya que la carga en cada uno de
los capacitores individuales conectados
en serie va a ser la misma que la carga
en nuestro capacitor equivalente y ya
que la carga en el capacitor equivalente
fue de 18 kilos la carga en cada uno de
los capacitores individuales será de 18
colones también ya que están conectados
en serie este proceso podría confundir a
algunas personas así que vamos a hacer
otro ejemplo en este caso digamos que
tenemos 4 capacitores conectados en
serie a una batería de 24 volts el
arreglo de estos capacitores luce
diferente a la del ejemplo anterior pero
todos estos capacitores siguen estando
conectados en serie ya que están
conectados uno atrás de otro en otras
palabras la carga no tiene otro
que es fluir directamente de un
capacitor hacia el otro así que estos
capacitores se siguen considerando que
están conectados en serie tratemos de
encontrar la carga almacenada en el
capacitor número 3 vamos a hacer el
mismo proceso que en el problema
anterior primero nos imaginamos
reemplazando todos los capacitores en
serie con un solo capacitor equivalente
vamos a usar la fórmula para encontrar
la capacitancia equivalente con
capacitores en serie cuando ponemos
nuestros valores encontramos que 1 entre
la capacitancia equivalente es igual a
0.1 25 tengan cuidado
recuerden que todavía tenemos que tomar
el inverso de este valor para encontrar
nuestra capacitancia equivalente y
encontramos que es de 8 hearts
y ahora que conocemos la capacitancia
equivalente podemos usar la fórmula de
capacitancia igual a la carga entre el
voltaje usamos el valor de la
capacitancia equivalente y el voltaje de
la batería ya que como tenemos un solo
capacitor pues el voltaje en este
capacitor va a ser el voltaje de la
batería así que encontramos que la carga
en nuestro capacitor equivalente
imaginario es de 192 colones
esto significa que la carga en cada uno
de los capacitores individuales también
será de 192 kilos y eso nos da la
respuesta de que la carga en nuestro
capacitor de 16 farage es de 192 kilos
incluso podemos ir más allá ahora que
conocemos la carga en cada uno de los
capacitores conectados en serie podemos
encontrar el voltaje que va a estar en
cada uno de estos capacitores nuevamente
vamos a usar el hecho de que la
capacitancia es igual a la carga entre
el voltaje en el caso del capacitor uno
tendremos 32 farah
igual a la carga que es de 192 kilos
entre el voltaje y podemos calcular el
voltaje a través del capacitor 1 que
encontramos es de 6 volts si
realizáramos este cálculo para todos los
demás capacitores conectados en serie
siempre teniendo cuidado de usar sus
valores particulares de capacitancia
veremos que la caída de voltaje en cada
uno de ellos va a ser en el capacitor 2
de 2 volts 12 volts en el capacitor 3
que es el de 16 caras y 4 volts a través
del cuarto capacitor que es el de 48
farat y la razón de haber hecho todos
estos cálculos es que quiero mostrarles
algo genial si sumamos los voltajes que
tenemos en cada uno de los capacitores
nos va a dar el total del voltaje de la
batería 24 volts y esto no es
coincidencia si sumamos los voltajes a
través de cada componente de cualquier
circuito de un
solo ciclo la suma de los voltajes va a
ser igual al voltaje total de la batería
y ese es el principio que nos permitió
derivar la fórmula para encontrar la
capacitancia equivalente de los
capacitores que estén conectados en
serie para derivar esta fórmula digamos
que tenemos tres capacitores conectados
en serie con capacitancia es de c1 c2 y
c3 que están conectadas en serie a una
batería con voltaje b ahora sabemos que
si sumamos los voltajes en cada uno de
los capacitores tiene que ser igual al
voltaje de la batería usando la fórmula
de capacitancia vemos que el voltaje que
está pasando a través de cada uno de los
capacitores va a ser la carga en ese
capacitor entre su capacitancia así que
el voltaje a través de cada capacitor va
a ser q / c 1 y en el otro será q / c 2
y en el tercero será q / c 3 no escribí
q1 q2 ni q3 porque la carga en cada uno
de ellos va a ser la misma
en que la carga en los capacitores
conectados en serie va a ser la misma la
suma de estos voltajes tiene que ser
igual al voltaje de la batería podemos
sacar q como factor común ya que lo
tenemos en cada uno de los términos del
lado izquierdo de la ecuación y ahora
divido cada lado entre q y lo hice así
para que vean qué es lo que tenemos del
lado derecho el voltaje a través de la
batería dividida entre la carga
almacenada que es igual a 1 entre la
capacitancia equivalente ya que q entre
b es igual a la capacitancia y aquí está
esta es la fórmula que hemos estado
usando y es así como la encontramos
viene del hecho de que los voltajes a
través de capacitores conectados en
serie tiene que ser igual al voltaje de
la batería